Frank schmückel 2002 bei Prozessbeginn
es ist das Ende einer langen Reihe von
Ausbrüchen und justizfehlern Schmökel
gilt als einer der gefürchteten
Kriminellen in Deutschland bei
Prozessbeginn hat er schon eine lange
kriminelle Karriere hinter sich zehn
Jahre im Maßregelvollzug einen Mord
mehrere Mordversuche eine Vergewaltigung
mehrere versuchte Vergewaltigungen und
sechs Fluchten in Deutschland beginnt
die Diskussion sind Täter im
Maßregelvollzug sicher verwahrt
das war schon was besonderes
insbesondere aufgrund der Medien
Aufmerksamkeit die dieser Prozess dann
auch mit sich gebracht hat die 14-tägige
Flucht dann der anschließende Prozess
und die Verurteilung der falschmöbel hat
ja im Anschluss noch eine riesig große
bundesweite Bedeutung gehabt über den
Umgang mit psychisch Kranken
Sexualstraftätern und in dem Sinne sind
eben noch hinterher Gesetze geändert
worden Frank Schmökel wächst in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern auf steckt schon
als Jugendlicher voll krimineller
Energie und kommt deshalb in einen
Jugendwerkhof eine Art geschlossenes
Erziehungsheim mit 18 Jahren beginnt der
schließlich als Rinderzüchter zu
arbeiten er fehlt immer wieder auf
Arbeit
ich sah dass er Hilfe brauchte haben
auch gefragt ob ein Arzt braucht dann
also guten Kopf geschüttelt
aber ich sah in seinem Blick dass er
Schwierigkeiten die Schwierigkeiten
hatte
psychisch das wird deutlich 1988 zum
ersten Mal versucht Schmökel ein Mädchen
zu vergewaltigen er wird gefasst
verurteilt im Rahmen einer Amnestie
kommt er gut ein Jahr später frei danach
beginnt er weitere Straftaten unter
anderem die Vergewaltigung einer
achtjährigen wegen dieser Taten wird der
Anfang der 90er in eine Klinik
eingewiesen
1994 gelingt Schmökel bei einem Freigang
die Flucht er vergewaltigt wieder ein
Mädchen das nur durch Zufall überlebt
das Urteil 14 Jahre Maßregelvollzug
weitere vier Fluchten folgen mit Anfang
30 ist die Liste seiner Taten lang und
weitkind unbekannt
die sind allerdings niemals so wirklich
in die Öffentlichkeit gekommen und auch
seine Ausbrüche weil natürlich auch der
Maßregelvollzug an sich und auch die
Politik natürlich überhaupt kein
Interesse hatte darauf aufmerksam zu
machen weil das ja wiederum dann auf
diese desolaten Zustände hingewiesen
hätte und dann der 25 oktober 2000 Frank
Schmökel darf trotz seiner Straftaten
aus dem Maßregelvollzug zu seiner Mutter
fahren begleitet von drei Pflegern im
Wohnzimmer seiner Mutter eskaliert die
Situation plötzlich Schmökel rammt einem
Pfleger eine Klinge mehrfach in den
Körper er überlebt nur weil der Notarzt
rechtzeitig zur Stelle war
unberechenbarer
wenn ich und somit zum töten bereit
also wenn man so will böser Mensch
Frank Schmökel verletzt aus seine Mutter
die zwei Pfleger die vor dem Haus stehen
können seine sechste Flucht nicht
verhindern
ich muss ehrlich gestehen dass ich
überrascht war darüber
überrascht aber auch davon dass er zwar
begleitet aber ein Besuch bei der Mutter
organisiert bekommen hat das fand ich zu
schlecht vorbereitet so dass im
Nachhinein gesehen
das was dann passiert ist ja eigentlich
vorhersehbar war Frank Schmökel
versteckt sich in einer kleinen
Gartenanlage am 2 November 2000
erschlägt er einen 60 Jahre alten
Berliner Rentner mit einem Spaten mit
dessen Auto setzt schmökelt die Flucht
fort
als junge Frau hatte man Angst gehabt
man wollte diese Bahnhof auf keinen Fall
begegnen und das war ja klar dass der
irgendwie in der Gegend ist weil der
hatte kein Geld der ist sicherlich nicht
irgendwo mit dem Zug ganz weit
weggefahren und man hat mit großem
Interesse damals die bundesweite
Berichterstattung in beobachtet mit
einem Großaufgebot ist die Polizei im
Einsatz mit Hundestaffeln und
Hubschraubern Anwohner sind besorgt
die Polizei ist überall im Wald bloß der
Verbrecher kann ja sich ein Auto nehmen
hierher kommen und ein Kind sich
schnappen und das war es da in der Nähe
von Bautzen wird das gestohlene Auto
sichergestellt noch fehlt der Täter kurz
darauf erhält die Polizei den Hinweis
eines gartenlaubenbesitzers und stürmt
den Unterschlupf von Frank Schmökel er
wehrt sich und wird durch einen
Bauchschuss verletzt seine letzte Flucht
endet nach 13 Tagen
die Leute konnten nicht verstehen wie
kann es dazu kommen also wie kann ein
Sexualstraftäter der so viel schlimme
Straftaten begangen hat einfach auf
Freigang gehen und das war ja dann
letztendlich auch in diesem ganzen Fall
der Knackpunkt dass man sagen konnte in
diesem Maßregelvollzug gab es eine
Person die darüber bestimmen konnte ob
ein Täter Ausgang bekommt oder nicht
durch den Fall Frank Schmökel wurde
diese bis dahin gängige Praxis
grundlegend geändert
geändert wurde ein Gesetz dass eben
nicht mehr nur der Leiter bzw der
zuständige Mediziner darüber entscheiden
darf ob ein Strafgefangener ob ein
Patient aus dem Maßregelvollzug
Lockerungen bekommt bzw auch auf
Freigang darf heute muss die
Staatsanwaltschaft mitentscheiden und
auch im Maßregelvollzug hat sich seitdem
viel getan was würden Sie
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen erheblich erweitert
das sind wirklich
hochsicherheitsanstalten in denen der
Maßregelvollzug untergebracht wird aber
auch die Therapie
Angebote sind erweitert worden das
Urteil vor 20 Jahren lautet lebenslange
Haft anschließend Sicherheitsverwahrung
Frank Schmökel wird wohl nie wieder in
Freiheit kommen